welcome to the long did our second
channel where I will be playing Age of
Empires with my good friend Benji from a
channel you should check out the tale
foundry Benji why don't you tell them a
little bit about what you do
hey everybody mostly I pretend to be a
robot which is a lot of fun but the
channel is mostly about writing and
storytelling most of what we do is we
find fiction that we really love try to
figure out why we love it so much and
then figure out if and how we can put
that into our own work so that's mostly
the premise of the show
yeah we're not a new content right now
that I'm super stoked about yeah yes so
you know we're all in the writing kind
of YouTube sphere and you know that's
how sort of we connected originally but
what we're doing today is we're just
going to talk about you know the process
of writing a book while we play Age of
Empires Benji oh is this the first or
second time that you have played Age of
Empires this is technically it's the
third because we and my computer
overheated and exploded
provided that doesn't happen this time
this will be the second like actual time
I played the game all the way through an
actual game yes so that that is why we
are playing on black forest with
moderates and all visible so that I can
see what he's doing and potentially help
him I'm gonna be playing as two Japanese
he's gonna be playing the Britons and we
don't know who were playing but let's
start the game I like to think my avatar
is representative of my skill level in
the game some fish so reversing the
Mongols and the Saracens which are both
cavalry organ a cavalry civilizations
and a good counter to cavalry is pikemen
helvetia's but yeah the Saracens are
pretty good you know Pike Lake is
appropriate because that it reminds me a
lot of my
okay so we're off to a good start
already because I remembered how to
click on things and interact with him oh
that's good that's good
you'llyou'll by the way if you've got
your little scat you'll know that there
are sheep around you should you should
get your sheep into your town center and
you should send your villages to kill
and eat them like yeah I'm in the
process of murdering a little creature
right now my Scout is trying to run
through a tree
okay so Tim your is this your first
novel right yeah so my goodness let's
just reminds me of how bad a multitasker
I am this is is this my first novel yes
at the moment I am writing a book called
I'm not telling you and I think I've
told you dingy so don't say anything
yeah you know but um it it is a fiction
book and I am about I don't know
probably 40 45 thousand words into the
second draft which I am really happy
with because you know I I didn't think
I'd get there this this quickly but I
have and I'm aiming to have the second
draft completed by the end of the end of
the year well probably within the next
few months and then from there I'll look
at you know editing and potentially if
they're draft but I'm gonna see where I
where I go from there from there that's
a thousand words is a good number
especially considering I think the
longest thing I have ever written and
finished was about twenty-two thousand
words so you're doing just fine
twenty-two thousand words you did a
novella yeah that was the one you
actually listened to a couple days ago I
think
wait that was twenty-two thousand words
I believe it was actually no it was
almost twenty thousand that's right
Wow okay that did not feel it like I
mean so I listen to the other day was
called automata on cue which is just a
fantastic title by the way it wasn't the
finally came up with it it I went
through a couple real stinkers to get
there
Devon of do you mind sharing what your
other titles what if I can even remember
it's like it's like trauma like locked
out of my mind and there was one
commenter when I was thinking about
titles and posting them for votes on the
community tab on YouTube it was like I'm
just so disappointed in you these are so
pretentious for the law typically
youtube comment like wait wait why to
angry about that but but I know I know
what you mean yeah but but you know I
don't know I'm fortunate I feel like to
have that kind of input period even if
it is too angry because it helped me to
re-evaluate my priorities and what I was
doing
and so I was gonna go with something
like what was it like a carousel of
broken dreams or something like that
it was carousel of broken dreams I'm
just hearing Green Day in that it wasn't
that but it was something like that it
was one of those things where like I'm
trying to put a metaphor into the title
but in isolation within the title and
it's like you can feel the pretense
dripping off it so yeah I I get what you
mean like I I think that's one of the
really hard things when you're writing
if you're trying to write with the depth
is trying to figure out am i writing
with depth or am I just being
pretentious I just started to start
making arms but instead I started
researching looms so no loom is good to
research looms good to research you
don't you're doing well
no III know you I know you mean that is
really hard to know sorry I'm a little
distracted right now because I'm trying
to try to remember where in the menu to
go to build a farm so that my people you
need to click on a villager and then
it's in the bottom left and it's the
little hammer with the with the pocket
of money as opposed to the hammer and
the sword and then you'll see the farm
is the second one down on the left also
you've got a couple of idle villagers
standing around you never want idle
villagers that's true I need to get
these two people producing textiles for
me stat you do that that's absolutely
true and you probably want to focus more
on wood and food at the start of the
game and then transition to gold and
then stone later on also they are
currently they're currently nope they're
not still and just sheep anymore they
were going to let's get back home so um
do you have any like novels that you
started to try to write and then
abandoned a part of the way through or
is this your first in genuine effort and
you're following all the way through
with it uh oh
I felt like you're half asking that
question because you know the answer and
it's painful horrible but no this is not
my first novel that I have completed
theoretically and it's also not even the
first novel that I've you know tried to
get published technically but I actually
know that it's it's nothing serious at
all it's it was it was a book that I
tried to get published and I ended up
getting a getting an offer from a
somewhat less than or
beautiful press when I was like 12 so it
doesn't count
at least I mean you might have dodged a
bullet there then yeah it definitely
dodged a bullet
okay let's get some walls up yeah so I
in terms of books that I have finished
as in like you would count as a
completed manuscript to a first draft
stage so what we're talking just like a
first complete draft that even if it's
terrible is is there well I can tell you
that I have done oh that is a nice
defensive position so you see this Hill
here in its second will um oh yeah that
little tiny thing yeah I was looking for
I was looking for like a but I see yeah
that Hill that Hill is beautiful because
archers do extra damage when they are
going facing downhill and yeah it's it
which means that um if you can build
towers and castles on there now you I
know you haven't got to the castle age
yet but um as a neighbor my friend I
have not gone to the feudal age yet
that's ok that's ok you're allowed to to
not be at the futile age it's ok this
the second channel extreme yeah exactly
I am gonna send up some set up some
walls for you because otherwise you're
probably gonna die
I appreciate that send them up on this
little mosquito bump up a hill over here
alright I suppose yet you're not used to
like yeah it is basically a little hill
that is really unfortunate though that
you have such an open area into your
base whether I have a really narrow but
look at this corridor here tiny little
corridor oh yeah how fabulous
for you that is super narrow meanwhile
mine is like an octopus with pathways
like spreading out into all the various
corners of the world yes so what I'm
actually going to try and do is channel
them towards my base rather than yours
okay harvest boars and goats right you
can harvest them yep they won't be there
excellent sources of food yeah my my
experience novel writing so far has just
been right about 70 pages and then
abandon it oh this is going to kill my
village shirt oh yeah no you need lots
of villages to attack them at once okay
okay you've got three villages right
next to your base no don't don't see it
another one just retreat to cinder he's
good he's gonna die please sit let them
please let your villages attack them
together this is the whole of Western
civilization this is why it never
started they all came single-file to
attack one boar
okay I'm sick I'm sick I appreciate that
set it up between me and this other boar
what you want me to set up a wall
between you and the other boar all right
you know that you know that yellow
button up at the top next to where it
says feudal age oh sorry what next to
where it says Dark Age yes click that
okay now take that villager and
take that villager and set them to doing
something it doesn't matter what just
look at whatever resource you need and
do that I'm super deep into getting to
the feudal age right now I'm about 70
food away from it and I am thrilled to
join the rest of the world are you in
the castle ain't yet I am hitting up to
the castle age and a little bit okay
we'll just wait all Eclipse you once I
get the technology to kill bored
efficiently but say yeah my experience
with novel-writing has pretty much so
far just been right about 70 pages find
something else I'm interested in and
then abandon it or realize at the 70
page mark there's so much I dislike
about my draft that this is not the time
that the book is gonna come out and
that's happened to be about four times
at this point which was one of the
reasons I went to short story writing
because I just felt felt like I didn't
have the skill if I was gonna fail
writing my first book you know four
times in succession maybe I need to
acquire some skills first oh crap I'm
already under attack now that's fair I
get what you mean I get what you mean
like a lot of people I I will I dunno
you know like try to go straight into
writing a massive novel and it's just a
bad idea
yeah I'm conflicted about it cuz like I
think you can learn most of what you
need to from from writing a novel but
there's something about finishing a
piece like like being able to look at a
whole thing in you know a complete work
and evaluate how it came out and what
you did to get there etc that just feels
different from you know working on the
same thing for a very long period of
time so unless you're like Brandon
Sanderson I just feel like short stories
are such a good gateway into into novel
writing into longer form fiction I
totally agree though I do admit I find
it immensely difficult
to write short stories like really I'm
not yeah I I find them a lot harder you
know you've got to be so much more
careful with what you're what you're
writing that's true you have to write
pretty lean which is it's not like a
fundamental skill that that just like
everyone has out of the gate with the
novel you can meander and have whatever
kind of a character exchanges you want
you can have a sides with a short story
if you try to do that stuff you start
pulling your hair out because you're
like you're 30 pages into your short
story and you haven't finished the first
act and you're like should this even
have three acts and then you got a
restart and it's it's pretty
demoralizing I would say I've had that
experience a few times actually the
novella I wrote was supposed to be a
short story it was supposed to be in the
ballpark of 7,000 words but after
listening that I'm sure you can
understand why it ended up novella yeah
that was a really good short story
though like how long did that take you
to write and by the way you should all
listen to it I do understand it is you
know 2 2 to 2 hours long but it is it is
very worth it well thank you yeah I am
I'm retro actively pretty proud of that
thing but while I was writing it I think
I told you this I was in a pretty deep
funk writing that thing because you know
I had a YouTube channel to run and I I
wasn't running it I basically put
everything on hold to write this thing
so it was gonna be my next video and
then like a month passed in two months
past and three months passed and it was
such a complex work the sunk cost
fallacy I just kind of threw it out the
window and wasn't like I can come back
to this later what I need to do is work
on my life right now I basically said
goodbye to all my work for half a year
and to make that thing and then I post
it on YouTube and it got like 9,000
views or so thing but I learned a lot in
the process I can look back at it retro
actively and it's a valuable project to
me am I going to do it again absolutely
not in fact that process led me to think
about how
I can economize a little bit and figure
out like ahead of time is this idea too
big for a short story yeah no that's
that's fair that I tell you get what you
mean I think you know I don't know I
think I've always I've always read a lot
more long stories so you know in a sense
like it's a it's a kind of like you're
used you you write what you're used to
you know yeah yeah I mean that was my
feeling too and I think that's pretty
natural when you're reading a lot of
novels and epic fantasy and stuff to
want to write that you know it's the
thing you're familiar with it's the
thing you're going to aspire to because
it's familiar to you
and then you set out to write it and
it's just this mountain in front of you
and you have no tools to scale it so
you're like figuring out you know as you
go like how to find handholds how to not
fall to your death yeah differently I
mean like I it took me four years to get
to the point where I could write the
second draft of my off my first book of
the world life of this book that I'm
currently you know currently on I've got
a question for you Tim why can't I build
a farm
do you have 60 food at 60 wood yes I
have almost a thousand wood well do you
not have a you do not have a mill that's
all you have to build that first yes
sometimes sometimes buildings to have
okay so I would suggest building your
mill in a nice open space like like this
because that's where you can that's
where you can build the most fields
around it you could build the most
fields around it exactly fabulous okay I
thought the the mill was kind of like
all the various camps you build where
you you build your farm and then you put
your mill down to save travel time
pretty much so
Ram no no they've gotta they've got to
bring it back as well okay all right
well maybe now I can actually advance a
little bit as a civilization that would
that would be excellent all right I need
to get a second town center up so what
experience do you have writing short
stories in that case it sounds like
you've tried it out a few times I have
very little in the grand scheme of
things I mean compared to what I've
tried to do with with novel writing I
I've written a few short stories I even
wrote a short story from the perspective
of Eva Braun who if you didn't know was
Hitler's wife
oh that sounds difficult if it's not a
great short story I'll tell you that you
could add more to the material being
difficult or to your skill as a budding
writer I would create that primarily to
it just me being a bad writer wasn't
very good yeah I I still feel that way
honestly every time I write something I
don't know I feel like that's never
going to be a point where I write a
short story I'm just like yeah yeah yeah
like I am great at short story writing
and writing in general and this is gonna
come out awesome I feel like it's always
gonna kind of be like I don't know like
I'll be lucky if this works yeah I get
what you mean I get what you mean I this
book that I you know I'm writing at the
moment second draft i I've been all of
my books come from a you know very
personal place and I think this is the
the first one that I have like really
been thinking about for this long
[Music]
sometimes when you're writing a bit
no no I wrote this the first draft of
this in 2016 and then after that I was
like hmm no can't really do it come
really to the second draft and okay it's
good by the way they're pressing on me
they're pressing over here but they they
are coming around
that's very good they're attacking you
for us because now that I built a mill I
can't seem to build the actual farm I'm
right I'm selecting my villagers got the
farm click right clicking on the patch
and gosh darn it and nothing is
happening you need to select a villager
and then you need to select you don't
need to right-click you need to lift
click is that really what I've been
doing wrong here you're doing
fantastically I I have a feeling we're
gonna lose this game because I have been
very distracted I can't imagine what
though no not at all neither it's a
complete mystery there was a moment
before we started recording where you
were like should we just play should we
just play the game this is absolutely my
fault I I have I blame you yeah I'm sure
I'll hear about this on Twitter for the
next year or so I'm sure this will
extrapolate out so whenever there is
something to blame anyone for it'll be
remember that time that time we
sacrificed two civilizations so that we
could talk about books I'm glad you
understand the gravity of your situation
it doesn't mean I regretted by any means
doesn't mean I'm penitent in the least
it just means I'm aware okay I should
theoretically yeah geez not getting the
resources I need
do you need any resources in particular
I actually have plenty because I was
accruing them while figuring out how to
left-click so I've been really dumb I've
been speaking into champions when I've
got freaking Japanese samurai I don't
know why dat that I don't even know what
that means
shame shame I knew I'm about to get
brushed by a bunch of cavalry so let's
get that them over here okay I think I
can make it into the castle aged in like
the next five minutes that's good
I just need golden food and you know
what I'll make some villagers yes
what's your population sitting at you're
like 20 minutes into this game I'm at 83
out of 120 also had a population of at
least 3 million you know I'm sure for
the first thousand years or so they they
had about 10 or 15 people you know what
you are you are right technically you're
right
alright I'm gaining on this now now I
can have 15 villagers so uh
oh well I'll be I'll be with all of you
shortly
they're at least pushing on me which is
good yeah fabulous maybe after they
destroy you by that point I'll be strong
enough to survive them hopefully by the
time that by the time they've destroyed
me they'll just be like don't be just be
coming for you and that they won't even
bother they'll just move on past maybe
what we could do is like a switcheroo
where like they destroy you and they're
so eager to kill me that they don't even
bother to sack your lands so then I'd
sneak out the back door come around
I sank your lens and then you know come
up come up from behind them that's
absolutely right yeah in a matter of
minutes okay let's get some gold
what's my make your towers stronger by
making shooting arrows I mean it's not
really that great because I'm not
speaking into towers so they go on there
they're going hard cavalry from what I
can tell on both of them they're also
coming with a lot more siege weapons
along something really cool about my
situation yes I still have roofs you
just to let that storage yes I I am okay
you need to build more houses yes I
agree with this let's grab this
honestly though these are like societies
of uber benches because they just they
they build homes on their own they build
farms on their own
[Music]
I suppose you're technically correct
okay I really need you to build a a
market okay I'll get to that I can can I
build it during the feudal age No yes
I'm not sure also you're currently
getting attacked by a single dude and a
battering ram
can you manage that perhaps I don't even
know where that is though it should be
okay I'm just sitting dudes there I'm
sitting to spare I'll send my Scout
after him well well my Scout died taking
this on I know they also have an art
group oh yeah yeah but that Scout is
gonna die I regret to inform you Tim
that although I may be able to fight a
boar now I still cannot fight other
soldiers that's okay
you know that's okay you you don't need
to to feel too bad about that I I you
just need to get the economy right right
okay okay
so I've just built a ton of villagers
I'll stick them on food
if you need resources do let me know and
I will do my best to give you some
resources oh yes
would would would allow me to make a
market you don't have any would uh not
not much I got 21 at the moment and four
people on it I actually just discovered
that little number on the bottom right
of the resource is how many people you
have gathering that research thankful
that's that is absolutely all have so
you need would I I'm not sure if I can
actually send you stuff until you on I
can alright here you go here's his 500
would excellent okay let's get these two
Idol villagers do something useful where
do you want this market I want your
market here okay because what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to clear a path between
the back of our two bases so that our
markets can go out things can go between
one another interesting a right right
next to this pool of water just just
down that area oh bloody hell
No do you think we're perhaps both
pretty bad at multitasking I think this
is something we're discovering this is
it is admittedly not my strong point but
I am going to run out of I'm going to
run out of gold if you don't need to
give me any gold oh my okay
the two people I sent over here to build
a market are being attacked by a leopard
yeah they should be able to take the
leap it out there it should be okay
why can they okay they can't fight a
boar but they can fight a leopard yeah
Bulls are like extremely Lethal in this
game to some piece powered I wish I
could make Boers four units stop
advancing you idiots
okay okay we're doing fine nothing to
worry about yet okay I'm some reason my
people are just not getting enough gold
are they gonna try it convert my dudes
yeah that's not happening I forget it I
forget that's something you can do in
this game it is did I don't think I've
told you that though I heard it when we
were playing with Daniel that that time
my computer exploded um you're working
on a book of short stories at the moment
right oh yeah technically I am yes
because you know I write short stories
for all the themed videos I do entails
entry I do like these mini series where
we take these deep dives into extant
bodies of work that we really like and
then I try to write a short story based
on what I've learned from those and it's
not like I'm not trying to replicate
something the author is done I'm just
trying to incorporate something you know
I think is transferable from their work
so I've got a bunch of those and it's
kind of cool because it's not an
anthology that shows off my skill as a
writer it shows off how much I didn't
know and how much I've learned by trying
to you know take lessons from other
writers so I think when I make it I'm
gonna try and kind of fill it as like
watch this person over the course of 20
some-odd stories develop their crafts
see I I just admire you know the your
audacity to put your writing on line
like I'm genuinely terrified of that
because you know people would obviously
have a lot of opinions on what I or my
writings like and that's not because you
know running is bad but I also know that
I've generally thought that my writing
is better you know has been writing it's
not being that great and when I look
back on it after a time but I suppose
that's the intro of like every author
yeah I mean it's weird it's interesting
that you see it as like bravery or
audacity on my part
because I I kind of see it as like
submission or I don't know if the term
is for this like giving up a little bit
where I'm just like you know forget it
I'm not going to write something
people are gonna dislike it it's gonna
happen I would rather just share it and
see what happens
no that's fair I mean III know that you
know obviously once you've got it out
there it makes it a lot easier to sort
of get over that hurdle yeah it's it's
like how it just take like having taken
the dive like ripping the band-aid off
although I will say I wasn't gonna do it
but what happened you've got people in
your base oh okay give me a second I
should be able to deal with them all
right I want you to click the click on
your town center and click the bell okay
I literally just queued up like nine
militia that's good militia they
certainly are units it can probably take
two crossbowmen yeah oh yeah nine
crossbowmen would allow you to take it
to take a dude's you can just send your
Villa send your villagers into your town
center Oh No okay okay okay okay
I've seen some dudes and I'm putting up
a castle who will be able to I am under
siege by two men
this is worse that then that time we had
to deal with the boar the great trauma
of your of your history dealing with the
boar there I did that yeah I appreciate
your help that was very useful to have
you there I think we I think we pretty
much had it under control but I
appreciate the the gesture I'm sending
in my my dudes
to kill the enemy by the way it's so
yellow should be hopefully wiped out a
little bit Oh fabulous yeah I have a
long-standing feud with yellow those
three pikemen should hopefully be able
to keep you safe I'm like I'm so
traumatized by two people entering my
village I don't even know what to do
anymore
yellows resigned see this book though
like for me people often ask me like
where do you start with a book and this
book definitely started for me with like
a carrot to rock the the character arc
of the main character and like I don't
know how you work in particular but for
me a lot of the time the struggles that
the characters are going through in fact
I've read your I've read your your I've
heard your automata on cue so I know
that for you a lot of the time the
characters in your story go through
similar struggles to what you're going
through with yes yeah I think that's
pretty common not mostly just um because
it's empathy right it's it's very hard
to know what an experience is like if
you haven't gone through it and I think
the most poignant stuff you'll ever
write it's stuff that is happening to
currently where you don't kind of have
to grasp and like try to remember and
recall or imagine what it's like it's
something you're going through right now
you just you just put it to the page
just commit right that's true
there's that degree of I think there's
definitely you know a degree of pretty
much just translating your experiences
to the page rather than trying to
imagine someone else experience someone
else
variances yeah although I will say it's
it's like wait I don't know it's like
way sexier to do it the other way for
some reason it's it's exciting to try to
envision something I've never been
through but the fundamental issue with
that is that I haven't been through it
so the thing you've got to do is like
comparative analysis like what
experience do I have that comes close to
this and then you have to do research
and both of those things require a lot
of like time and mental energy and stuff
so they're on their own they're just way
more psychologically taxing it's it's
way more of a barrier to actually like
starting to write this story
so having that empathetic place to start
just makes the process not only me a
little more genuine but but just way
easier yeah definitely I get what you
mean I I know what you mean by like oh
it's six year to do it the other way
because you know you we sort of worship
these authors who have the ability to
visualize anyone and anything you know
and that's kind exam it's it's a it's a
real skill but I and the sense like I've
always I've always described I've always
described writing as kind of an exercise
in empathy because it is I think and in
a way like the books that I write are
still exercises in empathy yeah I agree
with that completely
it's interesting to think about like
when you'd say exercise in empathy I'd
be curious to know how that translates
practically to you like like what
thoughts are you having as you write
like are you like I've got to go out and
have this experience before I can write
or are you like interviewing people like
what are you doing to get that
empathetic exercise that training you
need to write from those perspectives or
write accurately I think for me you know
a lot of the writing that I do is and is
is
kind of an engagement with those
hypotheticals I think a lot through like
what would I do if the situation came up
how should I react how could I react and
a lot of the time the different
reactions of various characters kind of
reflect different sentiments that might
have gone through my mind or struggles
that I've had with that particular kind
of scenario you're in the castle age I
did it you did it
I've got shingles on my roofs you do
have shingles on your roofs
congratulations
no more thatching here trogdor come back
another day but yeah I think I think
you're totally right I think the the
least truthful the most you know kind of
opaque ugliest characters I've ever
written our characters that I kind of
saw from a distance I was like okay I'm
trying to write a sadist actually the
worst character I've ever written was a
sadist when they said was to make us
quality oh do you mean like worst as in
the most horrible both pretty much
because she was pretty two-dimensional
and what I was trying to do with that
story I think it was a good idea for
this story but I was so focused on
character I was so let's make this
character driven I kind of confused
writing empathetically with with writing
interestingly and I was like let's just
give this character a real quirky
personality and real quirky motives and
at some point in the story it devolves
into torture pony and it's like this
this huge like 30-minute set up while
you're listening and eventually you just
get to the scene where somebody is like
being merciless or mercilessly butchered
and it's like where where did this come
from and why and I know as an author
what I was trying to do but other people
listening to it have to just be like
what the heck is this yeah I'm not sure
i 100% follow what you mean they are you
saying like oftentimes characters that
you write you know when you do them
badly it just becomes the sort of
heinous
you're throwing so much intensity at
them
sort of lose a reality well they become
caricatures become pages right
yeah and they create falseness within
the story by creating false motivations
so like I have this character that I
thought would be really cool as a sadist
for various reasons within the world
very emotionally damaged and you know
taking out her lack of control on other
people and I was so wrapped up in that
idea I didn't think about like
empathetically how would I respond in
these situations what would I do
I'm not a sadist but I've been angry I
felt those feelings I know what's
galvanized mates like want to punch a
wall or something like that you know
those very like Lord of the Flies
feelings that come from deeper than your
subconscious and I just my feelings yeah
I was actually writing a I was writing a
piece of description for a building the
other day and I was trying to decide
between two different pieces of
description either describing it as
straight out of straight out of ink
socks design handbook I don't know if
you know what being sock is English I
believe it does actually start for that
but it's from its from the dystopian
novel and it's from 1984 it's been a
while so listen to I was trying I was
trying to figure out should I go for for
in socks straight in socks handbook or
Stalinist how would you imagine
Stalinist architecture like if ice I'd
say that I'm historical neophyte I know
next to nothing so the things I do learn
I tend to learn for the purposes of
fiction and the place I got to was the
end of the the like Lenin's era of you
know Russian history so just before
Stalin
you know starts exerting a meaningful
influence so I don't actually know I
can't actually speak too well to that
but I'm curious what your thoughts for
starting that would be well I kind of
imagined the USSR was like known for
basically having carbon copy not carbon
copy but they have like it's a set of
designs for their architecture following
kind of this philosophy of everyone
having the same equal kind of you know
housing and whatever and and part of it
was you know state housing giving
everyone the opportunity to have quality
housing but the result of that is that
they had these uniform designs for they
had these uniform designs for all of the
different places all the different play
apartment complexes that that they've
built and so you've got these basically
giant cold concrete you know structures
that are just monolithic and I always
loved that kind of imagery it's very
very kind of terrifying and it's
definitely very imposing it kind of
sucks the life and variety and disparity
out of things yes yes going for it makes
me think of Kafkaesque stuff where like
just the sheer oppression of
architecture and the world you live in
it's not even other people doing things
to you it's just being part of a very
rigid system and then how how difficult
that is for a creative humans mind or
just a human's mind probably yeah no I
know what you mean
that's that's sort of what I'm going for
I was trying to figure out which one of
those two phrases kind of captured that
feeling bitter I'm trying to remember
I'm multitasking here so I'm trying to
remember what what are you trying to
figure out this rule building for this
is actually for my book it's actually
just an apartment complex that a guy
stays in okay yeah it's nothing even bet
it's not even that impressive yeah well
it's still cool though it's still a cool
comparison to make is that something you
think you would do like
explicitly like do you think you'd have
the character remark internally about it
or yeah it's trying to evoke it in the
description your I've read your your
writing just has so much more character
than mine like yours all of your all of
your you know people have all of you in
their narrators just have a ton of
character and let you can feel bleeding
through the page even though you know
you've got characters on top of your
narrator and I love that I mean
obviously it was Terry Pratchett II have
scanned the Saints that you were trying
to channel Terry Pratchett yeah if it
made me feel like I had a lot of legal
room to make these extremely
characterized you know different voices
like like a lot of the time especially
if you're writing more realistic
characters the things that distinguish
them are are nuanced the particularities
of how they handle the situation or how
they might you know respond to something
that's slightly more terse or more of
her beau's way or whatever but these
characters are like so they're they're
right on the cusp of being caricatures
the only thing that doesn't make them
caricatures is that they the story
doesn't melt to fit them they have
conflict you know in this story um so
I'm curious whether you're making like a
comparison between that and your writing
and I'm curious where you're going with
that
ah no not really I just my my writing
just feels I don't know it's it's so
hard to feel to figure out whether you
know your writing is kind of stilted or
more Leslie's character or whether it's
Oh
whether you just have a more subtle
style you know whether other people have
more explicit ones yeah we are obviously
you know the worst judges of our own art
and I think that's I think that's a good
thing I think when you're doubting those
things it means you're you're ready to
adjust you're ready to like you know be
open if you find something that you
dislike about your story but but when
you're that close I think it's I think
it's kind of healthy to have a feeling
like that if you're wondering if you've
held too much back maybe you know yeah
well at least that's how I feel and and
when I do feel that way the response is
often that like people people feel like
I've just hit the mark like I don't know
I guess I almost want to say if I feel
bad about something in a story and it's
not because I think I did it wrong
necessarily or I think you know I'm
being dishonest about the story often
often I guess that means I'm doing right
but that sounds so unintuitive and it
really that sounds pretty hopeless if
I'm doing something wrong if it feels
like I'm doing something wrong I'm
probably doing something right how is
the writer am I supposed to accept that
that that is that is really hard it is
incredibly difficult to be a good judge
of your work in both ways by the way you
know it's hard to know but it's good and
it's hard to know when it's bad it's
very easy to to kind of sit there and go
oh no this isn't any good but at the
same time oftentimes people will read
your book and they will they will think
that entirely different parts are a lot
more compelling and you go up well
really that's I don't I don't know if
that's any good yeah exactly and
actually part of me when they respond
that way I'm like no you idiot it's it's
terrible don't you get it and like I
would never say that obviously but like
my interview it's terrible don't you get
it what don't you understand it's awful
do you need any resources because I am
just drowning in resources right now you
know I'm actually okay
it's just that I need to build more
buildings I need to build a university
so that I can get into the the next age
here the Imperial age I believe this
will be the first time I've ever gotten
to the Imperial age
yeah well this will be just just
clearing some space I'm gonna by the way
I am going to I'm going to clear a way
for you to come through the back of
their base pikemen yeah also can you go
and oh good you've been upgrading your
people okay can you can you upgrade
those units so can you go into your
barracks and your archery range and can
you click the little thing below them
which will tell it which will say
upgrade to whatever yes I accidentally
clicked both halberd ear and two-handed
swordsman whatever that's no that's good
that is good you want both of those guys
to be upgrading the sound it makes me
build a monastery is really really
really really somehow intimidating but
like Wow yeah Tim he'll be what do I do
next what are you trying to do I don't
rightly know now I have this University
and you don't really need to do anything
with the university cause it's mostly
building upgrades buildings that you
don't have because you don't have a
castle how much stone do you have two
point six thousand
that's so much and you don't have any
castles okay we're gonna I'm not
anything to do with it and people have
been on it the whole game so we are
gonna do a thing where you were going to
bring all of your villages alright and
you are going to you are you are going
to build a ton of castles inside their
base alright so what you're gonna do is
we're gonna send in our units and you're
gonna go in one way and I'm gonna go in
the other and I'll go in first because I
always bail send all your units all the
units that you think you're dying but
then after you've seen to your units
into attack then you'll send in all of
your all of your villages because at
this point in the game it doesn't matter
if they break harvesting your resources
that much and I can always send you
whatever resources you need I'm on my
way in
finally yep so we're doing a Trojan
castle that's what we're doing yeah yeah
basically
I've actually I've actually found that
this book that I've been writing has
been I've thought a lot more carefully
about it than I have for any other that
I have for any other book like on an on
a phrasing level like you know I think a
lot more about why am i including this
particular piece of description and
criticizing it on those grounds a lot
more I I think that's honestly just
because I've been you know I've been
I've been thinking a lot more about a
bit about it because of my channel
partly but also you know I've been
working a lot more on reading fiction
and studying why fiction works and
figuring out why you know what why do
good writers include certain bits of
dialogue or description or you know
because bits of dialogue or description
and it's it's been it's been really
fulfilling to kind of see it see see
that in other books and try and
translate that to mine you know I think
there's some really interesting stuff
with a lot of writers where they only
include stuff that's like really
relevant or will come up later
but of course there are also other
writers who just kind of include
everything because it adds to theme and
atmosphere and what the whole place kind
of just feels like and trying to find
out that balance but more importantly
like I've been thinking a lot more about
what's the reason behind this it has to
give a second purpose every line has to
have a second purpose that's kind of
been my motto for this hmm that's really
interesting I don't I think a different
way
during my writing but it kind of sounds
like that but like you're making a
transition from like an amateur writer
into like that that that valley of the
dunning-kruger curve
you know what I mean we're like when you
have never written something but you're
reading novels it kind of feels like oh
like it's just writing right I know how
to write I can do that so you get all
excited and stuff then you go and try to
do it and I think one of two things
ends up happening either you think
you've written your magnum opus and you
think you're a genius and there's truly
no saving you at that point you try to
write it and you realize it's just
terrible and it's way harder than you
thought and you you either give up or
keep plugging along and eventually
develop skill and you know on the
dunning-kruger curve there's this valley
where as you do more of it and acquire
more experience your confidence goes
down and at the bottom of that Valley is
where most people give up so it kind of
feels like you're like cresting the
bottom part of that Valley we're like
you tried write novels for a long time
you stopped for a while because it just
wasn't working out started to acquire
more experience with what like writing
in general and now you're trying it
again and it feels like you have enough
experience to feel like a little bit
more confident or at least have some
stuff to think about you're not just
grasping at straws hoping what you're
writing will turn out well
yeah potentially I mean I I think I
think you know you've definitely got to
go through that part where you look
really critically yet your work and then
you go okay is this is not great I've
got to be able to fix this like I had
this conversation the other day with
with people on discord about whether you
can do good writing fast and whether
2,000 words in a day is a lot of words
to erisa to a Briton and I sort of had a
disagreement I basically said that I I
don't believe when you're an
inexperienced writer that you can do
good writing fast and the key word there
is an experience because I I have yet to
probably see writing from an
inexperienced writer that is either
[Music]
good and quick or rather than good and
slow mm-hmm what do you think that I I
think I agree with you pretty much the
thing is I think you can write quickly
but I think the first version of it is
pretty much always gonna be bad unless
you're extremely lucky or or you're well
then if you're self editing in the
process it's not gonna be a fast process
so I think you can write quickly but but
I think if you want to write really
quickly and you want it to be really
well you're probably gonna be writing a
lot more because you're gonna write a
first draft that is probably really
terrible because you just done it all
out without checking it without thinking
it through then you know you get to go
and write the second draft and you
already have an impression of your own
work you're familiar with it yeah
the second draft like you go through and
you you definitely people boss often
asked me and I said I've been hoping to
sort of do it in one draft and I go you
know we're not all crap I forgot this
name The Importance of Being Earnest Oh
Oscar Wilde
Oscar Wilde he wrote The Importance of
Being Earnest like a weekend and crazy
yeah I know I know and I'm just like
where we are not Oscar Wilde I am NOT a
scholar most importantly you know you
are not Oscar why III I think that
unless you're a prodigy unless you're
incredibly an incredibly good or lucky
the likelihood of you writing something
very very good on your first try is
pretty low and from that I I have
noticed that there's a real difference
in how you approach a book
psychologically in the second draft
which is that in the first draft you
know you're trying to get all the words
out and get all the plot points right
and get all the beats there and when
you've sort of got that already down the
second draft lets you go through and you
suddenly you know going you're looking
at what you've written and you're
thinking about it more intensely because
you've got that stuff behind you and
allows you to be a lot more critical of
yourself and know where you're wanting
to go on a kind of more Mira textual
level yeah absolutely
and we've talked about this a bit I mean
I've thought a lot about this process or
this part of the process and I really
feel like you you don't know your work
until you've tried to write it and
that's maybe one of the reasons Oscar
Wilde's is able to write so quickly
because like the importance of being
earnest is hardly probably the first
thing Oscar Wilde wrote and he was
prolific at least with letters and
correspondence and stuff he was writing
all the time so I'm sure there's a skill
he's developed with familiarizing
himself with his ideas as he writes and
maybe that's something you can do with a
lot of time but usually for most writers
I think it's going to be that you don't
know your idea very well until you've
tried to articulate at once and run into
the problems can have in the process of
articulation then once you've run into
those problems and seeing you know how
how inaccurate the idea has turned out
compared to what you envisioned then you
can go back and be like okay so maybe
maybe this thing needs to be more that
way etc etc but just try to do it all in
the first draft you're definitely not
probably going to to write the thing you
meant to write no okay we need to push
bring all of your units up to here all
my soldiers all of your soldiers and all
of your villages oh okay is there a good
way to select all of them double-click
on any villager oh my god I did I did
not know I could do that now it seemed
to them all to that point where I have
my I have my little siege engines going
siege engines going okay all right I'll
just walk them up behind ends and get
your get you
units there first my soldiers yeah all
your soldiers in there as well okay all
right they're on their way it's
frightening it's it like it feels like
they're funneling in toward their debt I
know they're not but I trust you Tim so
I want you to build a castle here as
soon as I attack all right and then
build a castle around here okay as best
you can and then build another castle
like here all right you ready I'm just
gonna destroy these I can hear you have
you died oh you're kidding me we were so
close oh hang on hang on I can invite
you into a game again wait is your
computer still did get it up and running
and we'll get that game up again well I
mean I was ready to destroy them for the
past like 20 minutes it is really hard
to keep a conversation life coherent
while also playing a game
sentence and then reflected wait what
did I just say that particularly I said
something about you know thinking if
it's and I've written it it's probably
gonna be good I sort of took that is a
little bit hyperbolas hyperbole is a
word hyperbolic there we go that's the
word I'm trying to go for I'm a good
writer you just let me know when that
started up I probably should have just
Microsoft age jeez I will have to would
like to record another episode of this
at some point because having someone
else do really helps yeah it's not
exactly the most interesting subject
everyone else the process itself is very
hard to make interest page yeah
committing symbols to a page
I am a dreadful realization about you're
not it's sort of like you know it's sort
of like sitting there and saying that I
guess all we do in life is try more
efficient ways to acquire food and then
it's like is that all my job is that
makes writing that or wrong it just
means visually and engaging which is
something I've encountered which I know
really trying to find ways to bring
their occupation platform and you know
you're immersed in your writing while
you're doing it so it's hard to have
conversation people on the live stream
and yeah yeah I mean there's not much
movement on the page OS in in a sense
you know it's almost entirely static
except for a tiny little cooker moving
along creating little symbols on a page
putting symbols to a page I cannot
believe your computer bummed out at that
point it was it was I'm so sorry
everyone for this being our first
episode this is why it goes on the
second channel yeah I suppose so I am
the book that I'm currently writing has
been like like it's really emotionally
closed for me you know there's sort of a
distance to a lot of experiences for a
lot of writers you know it's sort of
more of a creative exercise it's an
exploration of oh this would be cool and
I want to kind of explore it you might
get attached to the characters but that
becomes secondary or at least it comes
second to how you sort of approach it
initially but for me like that emotional
attachment was there from the start
because of the issues the characters
deal with and it feels more like putting
a lot of things in my life to the page
rather than and then translating them
through a fictional kind of lens rather
than putting stuff to a page and then
finding that emotion there and
developing it and cultivating it and I
that's why it took me it's almost like
like three to four years to get to the
point where I was like no no no I'm
ready to do this again because it also
allows me to bring a new perspective to
what I was writing at that point because
I've gone through so much and done so
much in this particular area which is
mental health and I am really happy with
the improvements that I've made like
there's a lot of there's a lot of
linguistic choices that I made back then
that I was like oh I can see what I was
trying to communicate about what we
should be saying about those sort of
stuff but it didn't come through because
I didn't have the knowledge that I do
now you know but you feel like this this
closeness to not only makes the story
more genuine but easier to write like do
you feel like you'd be laboring a lot
more in a sense in a sense yeah I get
what I get what you're saying but I
think that
I think that it definitely makes it
easier in the sense that like the depth
the emotional depth or the thematic
depth that you're wanting to put into
the story already feels like it's there
rather than having to manufacture it and
because you've already got it you've
already got it in you
the difficulty is you know trying to
actually get that down on the page so
the reader feels at the same way you do
because they won't necessarily and like
even though you might write something
and you're seeing like these extra
layers of depth to a particular line
dialogue or a scene sometimes you don't
manage to capture that accurately
because it's it's not it's not really
empirical we really engage our audience
cognitively because it's like it's page
right so when they different emotions
and that's one of the things about
poetry
I really admire and and didn't
understand for long
that like all these weird things poets
do the verse the meter all the tools
assonance rhyme but they're using it's
not just to have fun it's it's to create
emotion you're using devices and
language to and it's a really hard skill
it's a really hard thing to learn how to
use really what it's like abstract
expressions of thought to you know
replicate something we're experiencing
before the audience so I definitely
believe that would take a very long time
to do and I can see how actually with
that wait you know the trying to
accurately transfer that stuff it could
even actually be harder because you want
them to know what you're going through
and it's not so much like oh they can
they can feel how they feel about it I'm
sure on some level that's true but
because it's so dear to you you know
yeah yeah again what you mean
Oh why'd you in my computer is okay all
right I just need to seem to an invite
are you ready for me to send you an
invite yes yep okay just do that you are
not online
quiet you um building on like Canada
that disconnect between what you feel
and what you can put into words and also
connect instead to what I said before
about not knowing whether or not you're
being deep or just pretentious I sort of
have that struggle because one of the
things I've done for this book is I am
using I am using linguistic cues from a
poem it's not a famous poem it is a long
poem and it's a pretty old poem and it's
a reinvention of the hero in Leander
myth the Greek myth which is basically
about two lovers on either side of the
house pond which is a giant river down
through the Dardanelles I think it is
and it's the the summary of the story is
that hero and Leander Leander is one of
them is like a nun type figure and the
other is like from you know pursuing
pursuing her and he would swim across
the Hellespont to get to her every
single night as jazzy would try because
he was falling in love with her and then
eventually he would drown inside the
Hellspawn trying to reach her and the
important point being that she would
leave out a candle a candle or a light
on her on her in her tower so that he
can see his way across the Hellespont
when he's swimming towards her and all
right you're on I've seen two an invite
it is it is significant hearing this
part of the inspiration for your story
oh yeah and basically she would leave
out this light for him and he would swim
across
Swigert and mind he would know where she
is but of course one night the wind
blows out the candle and he ends up
drowning trying to reach her and then
she throws herself off a cliff seeing
you know seeing her lover die and that's
like a common thing in in Greek
mythology you know those sort of tragic
love you know types of stories Orpheus
and Eurydice I think it's another one
that sort of thing although she she
doesn't kill themselves doesn't matter
never mind the one that pushes the thing
up the hill all right you're in no
you're not in why are you not in I'm
sitting you another invite so like
there's a poem about this story that I
am drawing from linguistically and there
are phrases of that poem scattered
throughout the book
and particular symbols or things from
that story I used as symbols in the book
and people listening to this the poem is
not relevant in the way you're thinking
it's relevant it is it is probably a lot
more abstract than you're thinking but
that to me like that that level of depth
there it's very easy to think oh you
know I'm throwing this in but the
audience is never gonna pick the stuff
up they probably have never heard this
poem and if probably you know they will
not recognize the language that is used
throughout the story did you get the did
you get the invite okay tell me when
you're back in the game because it won't
work to Lin oh you are now playing let
me know when you're on the main page
that menu
it sounds really difficult it sounds
like I'm okay it shows my profile now
but it says I'm not signed in let me see
it but it sounds like gonna be hard to
sell with the audience because obviously
they they don't get this
will it feel vestigial to them or do you
feel like you've tied it enough in
telling the story that it's not just
like some weird diegetic tag along I
mean like on the one hand I don't know
and I was reading through the first
chapter again and I did recognize one of
these quotes and I was like oh man I
know it looks cool to me but to anyone
who hasn't read the poem they're not
gonna get what this is even referencing
so I have to take it out and it just
looked like purple prose when I was when
I was using it in that first chapter but
also the first chapters we've got to be
a lot clearer you've got all be a lot
more you you know you don't have words
to waste on on pretty language
necessarily and are not not pretty not
pretty language but you can't risk
nearly as much in the first chapter as
you can in perhaps later chapters and so
I did take that out I think to me it's
it's a it's a it's more of an easter egg
and it's a it's a thing that I think if
people find that but like ah that's cool
but it's not necessary to get the depth
of the story to get the themes of the
story and it's more of an analog for the
themes with the story rather than the
themes come through this analog sorry
what I mean by that is you don't need to
understand this particular poetic
instance to get the themes of the story
you get them outside of that but this
will perhaps it's a connection that if
you know it's there is a nice thing to
see
and yes I do
it reminds me of language it's so brief
and it's just work that is really good
yeah yeah I suppose it's it's it's
having layers but the audience doesn't
necessarily need to get them and it
doesn't necessarily make the book like
it doesn't make the book that much
deeper it's just it gives it layers that
otherwise would not have and doesn't
lose anything for having weaving this in
and you had it at like you know the
climax of chapters and stuff like that
something that really bugs me is when
someone works something like this into a
story and then at the climax they they
use something that is like a clue or
like an include just implicit they make
some allusion or reference to it at the
climax and that's supposed to be the
climax of the story if you don't get it
and you get to climax and that happens
it's totally that's happened to be in a
few stories about that but like all this
other action what about that like
shouldn't you should you should take the
invite by the way yeah now it's working
okay now it's working ah finally
I'm so sorry everyone next time we'll
try and be a bit tighter we've got it
prepped up sup anyway we're coming up on
an hour and a half I I was actually
going to do this tomorrow morning by
myself but I think it's actually better
with two people you know would you be
keen on joining me again for another
type of thing about that later yeah all
right okay are you ready DUP you're good
to go it says in order to participate in
this lobby lobby you must download so
yeah that's yes yes you just got to do
that it'll download the game to you like
we did that other time probably
shouldn't what download this thing so I
pressed X thinking it would okay I sent
you I scene to another invite take it
okay here we go
I won't I won't X anything this step all
right so where's the download
incidentally I've actually done that
with stories where I've written a really
really implicit thing climax hang on
hang on
have you have you found the download
before we continue us is there a button
to the right of what are you sealing
your screen right now wait can you just
go clear it can you click around okay oh
I'll add something I did this a lot as a
new writer because I felt like it needed
something there had to be some punch at
the end climax or something and then
I'll show people and the wow that was so
amazing that thing and they'll read
stuff into it that isn't there and it
suddenly makes the story so great so
like while I can't recommend you do try
to do that it's just it's so interesting
to see how effective the suggestion of
depth can be for people who are looking
for it right yeah and I actually agree
and I think the part of it the place
into that is that obviously you and I
both have internet followings which will
affect it in ways I'm sure you're
familiar with which is that people want
to believe you know you have that skill
and depth which can be intoxicating but
it's it does also mean you've kind of
got to be aware of you know am I
actually good here
also click already and it'll
automatically do it
intoxicating but more than anything I
find it really intimidating that there's
an audience who expects things and I I
know the majority of them will just be
happy to get pretty much anything right
but I don't know it's somehow it's even
worse that I know they'll just I'm super
grateful I'm super glad to have the
support network but it's almost like
creating period kind of outweighs the
actual merit yeah it's hard for me to
believe that the praise actually means
it's good because the praise might just
mean you know they like yeah I get what
you mean
all right okay are you ready to push
I I am like always you know afraid that
like my book it's it's definitely not
what I think a lot of people will come
up with do you find that you write stuff
that people don't think you normally
would
well I think if you listen if you look
at the variety of content on the channel
and deal with the writing short stories
I've written I think I hope I've picked
myself pretty pretty well as a variety
writer we're all just trying a bunch of
different things so at this point I
don't think I'd surprise anyone too much
by writing just about anything realistic
or historic ya know that that's that's
fair I mean III know you definitely have
kind of this a a tendency towards I
think well I won't speak for you but I
think you're a tendency towards like how
to put it you have a we as a slight
absurdist edge that's interesting that's
not a descriptor I've heard before but
I'm not opposed to it but I what you
mean by and it's not like it's not like
oh yeah tell me more
it's it's genuinely like please like
what what makes you move all right let's
move in our troops and then I'll tell
you so you want to select all of your
villages right now go onto the military
buildings on your thing no no just click
on click so click on the castle so get
them to build a castle but put it put it
like here
my computer just died all right good
mind okay that's fine I'm a National
youtubers set up with this is what
happens when you do your career off one
laptop yeah that's okay you're doing you
did well the conversation I had with you
and Daniel the other day when I was like
oh yeah but look I have a pretty nice
computer though and I described it I
like the price bracket I bought it you
guys are both like Benji you don't have
a nice computer no you don't it's it's
not that great with light and it's got I
mean I actually have a print of the
computer so I actually kind of know what
you're talking about
but no unfortunately predators like good
but they're definitely on top of the
range or anything back in the old days
before the new normal I would go to
coffee shops a lot so I could set up
with my computer
I'd be working and if I ever made eye
contact it was my head floating about
six seven inches above the word predator
in big silver letters would you like to
know your stats for this game by the way
okay so i got twelve thousand four
hundred eighty six military points take
a guess at how many you got take both
take an accurate guess yeah top thousand
four hundred and eighty six I'm gonna
guess I got two thousand but my
hyperbolic guess is like five you got 40
you killed three units and lost nine
[Music]
probably I killed 760 and lost 170 but I
was just because I had a castle stacked
you actually did pretty well on economy
you you got 2977 on economy which was
better than both of the both of the the
AI and you collected 8,000 would
thirteen thousand food mm stone 3000
gold you know you were doing pretty well
and then technology yeah well you
certainly have a score there to be
honest you actually you're actually
pretty similar in technology but uh the
timelines pretty interesting I I don't
know if like you'll be able to see on
the video when it goes live but the very
one watching the dark stuff the dark
color so I'm blue he's red than the two
AI a yellow and green and the dark
colors are the military population of
the world at the time and the
right colors are the the civilian
population anyways that is all thank you
very much for joining us Benji
joining me and I hope we can do this
again sometime where your computer
doesn't crash will discuss more stuff
this was fun for a first episode I am
always game to talk about light early
off early YouTube things it's just it's
super cathartic so yeah let me know when
another opportunity like that arises and
I'll take it even if it comes I have
manage of floundering civilization okay
okay sounds good the rest of you stand
early and I'll see you next time in the
future